where do you come from ?
Gallia
France ?
Bonjour, ça va ?
D'où venez-vous ?
Lyon
A l’origine, était le Chaos.
La Terre, Gaïa pour les Grecs, fut la première entité à en émerger.
C'est donc la plus
grande des divinités
ni créée ni enfantée, apparue sans l'aide de personne
elle porte les sommets les plus hauts et les gouffres les plus profonds.
Ces lieux sauvages sont
inviolables, protégés par des forces divines,
ils ne sont pas faits pour les humains.
Les uns dominant le monde sont associés au règne des dieux,
les autres, insondables et obscurs,
aux malheurs et à la mort.
La montagne, vers laquelle le regard s'élève, est le lieu privilégié de la spiritualité,
qu'elle soit religieuse ou non.
Les sommets,
inaccessibles à la plupart des mortels sont
les lieux les plus mystérieux qui soient.
Les sentiers empruntent les cols mais jamais les sommets.
S'y rendre est un choix en même
temps qu'une épreuve.
Le cheminement est long, souvent difficile, parfois périlleux.
L'accès aux sommets peut alors s'apparenter au pèlerinage,
l'effort physique et moral
devenant une illustration de la dévotion
qui anime le grimpeur.
Une fois atteints, les sommets sont investis
de symboles qui témoignent de la réussite
de l'entreprise: cairns, croix, chapelles,
voire monastères gigantesques.
Merveilles de la nature, rondeurs de Gaïa,
ce sont les assises des dieux.
L'altitude abolit une partie de la frontière
entre l'humain et le divin.
C'est l'approche, au sens physique du terme, des forces supérieures et primitives,
puisque le Chaos, grand Tout
originel, peut aussi désigner l'espace séparant
le Ciel de la Terre.
Pourtant, c'est en approchant de cette frontière
qu'elle se matérialise vraiment.
Atteindre le promontoire, au prix d'un effort important
rappelle au pèlerin sa condition de mortel:
l'essoufflement de la montée, une courte
ivresse au sommet, la nécessaire redescente.
Sa place n'est pas en haut.
Pour les Grecs de l'Antiquité, ce sommet,
lieu par excellence du mythe et de la religion,
c'est l'Olympe.
Olumpos étymologiquement
«coupant le passage» ou «entouré par les nuages »
tient son nom de sa réalité géographique.
Cette montage est une frontière physique et psychique
qui sépare le monde divin du monde humain.
Frontière physique d'abord puisque l'Olympe
est un ensemble de sommets qui surplombe la
plaine de Macédoine, et s'élève à 2 917
mètres avec le pic du Mytikas.
Frontière psychique ensuite car, ce point
culminant d'un pays montagneux, a été choisi
pour héberger les douze dieux du panthéon local.
C'est là que les secrets sont gardés,
les décisions prises, les destins scellés.
Si Delphes est le centre du monde mythologique,
l'Olympe en est la capitale.
Atteindre le sommet c'est donc pour nous,
atteindre la connaissance, briser le secret
du divin, voir ce qui par définition est
retranché à la vue.
Et tout devient clair.
Pour une fois, à la question que nous posons
dans cette odyssée, la réponse est simple.
Que découvrent les archéologues sur l'Olympe?
Rien.
Sur le lieu le plus cité des récits héroïques,
à l'endroit mythique par excellence, pas
de vestiges.
Mais ne faisons pas semblant d'être étonnés, ce n'est pas une surprise.
L'ascension n'aura fait que confirmer ce que nous savions déjà.
Le rappel de cette évidence,
par l'expérience sensorielle, par la présence
sur les lieux, permet de nous convaincre définitivement
des intuitions que nous avions eu ailleurs.
Les mythes et les vestiges archéologiques
n'opèrent pas dans le même monde.
L'illusion de la correspondance entre les vieilles légendes et les vieilles pierres
ne peut plus tenir sur l'Olympe.
Aboutissement de notre voyage,
ultime épreuve dressée sur notre route,
la montagne sacrée révèle la supercherie.
Cette montagne n'abrite aucun dieu.
Delphes n'est pas le centre du monde.
Œdipe n'a pas
chassé la Sphinge.
Agamemnon n'a pas régné sur Mycènes.
Athènes n'a pas vu s'affronter
les dieux pour elle.
Santorin n'abrite aucune Atlantide engloutie,
ni Cnossos, aucun homme-taureau.
Leur réalité est tout autre,
ce sont des villes, des palais et des sanctuaires érigés,
parcourus, et oubliés parfois par des sociétés très anciennes.
Redécouverts, ils révèlent
une extrême complexité et leur connaissance
approfondie n'est possible qu'au prix d'un
travail long et méticuleux.
Très loin des récits mythiques et de leurs verdicts définitifs.
Malgré tout et sachant cela depuis le début,
nous avons joué le jeu. Le jeu de la mythologie.
Car c'est la porte d'entrée de la connaissance.
Le mythe, s'il ne correspond à aucune réalité
historique, remplit tout de même deux fonctions
indispensables.
D'abord c'est une publicité.
La meilleure qui soit.
S’intéresserait-on autant à
Akrotiri sans le mythe de l’Atlantide ?
Cnossos accueillerait-elle autant de visiteurs sans
cette histoire d’homme-taureau ?
Se serait-on seulement arrêtés à Thèbes si ce n'est
pour Œdipe?
Sans doute pas.
Mais ensuite, et plus important encore le
mythe est notre aide-mémoire.
Ce sont les récits, qui portent les images et les émotions, qui sont le support de la mémoire.
Les éléments de mystère et de fantastique
sont alors autant d'accroches pour le souvenir futur.
Plus que les chiffres et les détails scientifiques.
Chercher à replacer les événements décrits
par les mythes dans la chronologie de l’histoire
de l'humanité, c’est manquer sa cible,
puisqu’ils ne sont pas du même monde :
monde des idées et des songes pour les mythes,
monde des découvertes matérielles ou factuelles
pour les sciences.
Vouloir les confondre est une tentation compréhensible:
un discours sensationnaliste remporte toujours
l'enthousiasme.
Au contraire, vouloir trop séparer ces deux mondes,
imagination et raison,
c'est prendre le risque d'enfermer les sciences
dans leur discours technique, de les marginaliser.
Convoquer les mythes sans y souscrire, mais
en sachant ce qu'on leur doit,
voilà peut-être
une juste réconciliation.